una estimación me llamo vacila vacío
tengo 26 años me considero un
revolucionario como la mayoría de los
sirios que detestan y se oponen al
régimen rojo pero lo que me distingue es
que fui detenido por las fuerzas de
seguridad cuando empezaron los eventos
hago parte del grupo de 24 personas que
llamaron los hijos de la libertad
[Música]
para mí los hijos de la libertad es la
chispa de la revolución están
estrechamente ligados
[Música]
los hijos de la libertad de los que yo
hacía parte era un grupo de jóvenes
verdad
en febrero de 2011
el régimen sirio nos acusó falsamente de
haber escrito mensajes sobre los muros
del colegio mensajes políticos en contra
del régimen
luego nos detuvieron
cuando los servicios de seguridad nos
llevaron a nosotros los niños y los
jóvenes se provocó una inmensa ira entre
nuestros padres
[Música]
para ellos no había nada más que hacer
que salir a las calles a manifestar y
fueron esas manifestaciones las que
desataron la revolución fue la chispa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
era viernes 18 de marzo de 2011
fue un gran día el primer día de la
revolución siria
en esa época yo estaba en la capital
damasco en el centro de detención para
destino estaba en un estado psicológico
lamentable había perdido toda esperanza
pero en derá era todo lo contrario
esteban
fue una época optimista el pueblo
reclamaba sus derechos la reivindicación
principal era que liberaran a los
jóvenes
es decir a mí ya mis amigos dos días
después de las manifestaciones de los
liberaron después la revolución continuó
y yo me uní a los manifestantes sin
dudarlo
cuando estábamos en la cárcel nos
torturaron nos golpearon nos insultaron
pero no éramos más que unos niños nos
obligaron a decirles que habíamos
escrito esos grafitis pero en realidad
no tuvimos nada que ver con todo eso
[Aplausos]
pensábamos que si seguíamos diciendo que
nosotros habíamos escrito ese grafiti
eso podría infectar a que las personas
se manifestaran la revolución me había
empezado
pero poco importa si escribimos o no ese
mensaje nos detuvieron y nos torturaron
esa es la realidad nadie sabe quién
escribió en sus grafitis investigué
mucho sobre ese asunto
con quién se va a comer ese pájaro que
tiene hambre
porque se come al pájaro se lo come
undone vivo aquí en samsung y trabajo en
el edificio
hoy para mí lo más importante es que mi
hija mis hijos
a su generación de manera general más
tengan conciencia de lo que pasó aquí
están
soria
voy a contarles mi historia por supuesto
y decirles cómo estalló la guerra en
siria vivo el día a día y mi espíritu
siempre está preocupado con siria
y por mi familia que se quedó allá pero
personalmente no pienso en el futuro más
allá de las cosas más siempre que no
logró proyectar me hacia grandes cosas
a ver